[Music]
hey everybody what's going on it's
tuesday
yeah i think okay i don't know i wasn't
sure for a second i had to think about
it um you think that i would know by now
because i have to keep track of like all
the days for the shows and everything
but sometimes i forget like at the end
of the day
so uh return to salem's lot we okay so
here's this was my fault
i'll take the blame for this one
um what ended up happening is that i
think i was scrolling through shutter
last night because i was like well
you know we need a movie to talk about
on the thing and it's just kind of like
i said i'm kind of tired so i don't want
anything really long and i don't want
anything like really complicated or
heavy or anything like that so i said i
just kind of want something kind of fun
and dom and [ __ ] like that
so i was scrolling through shutter and
they had the original salem's lot which
we've already talked about
and then i thought to myself oh [ __ ] i
think over on hbo max or amazon prime or
something like that i said oh they have
returned to salem's lot which i don't
think i've ever seen and i don't really
ever see anybody talking about it so i
said well let's have a look at that
and see what that's all about and then
like when we started watching it i
realized that it had been written and
directed by larry cohen for christ's
sake which i didn't even know
um who did cue the winged serpent it's
alive the stuff he did all that kind of
god told me to
so he did all of those movies and i was
just kind of like oh okay you know this
should be an interesting oh and michael
moriarty is in it who was also in the
stuff and was in a bunch of other movies
um
this it's not great not great yeah
what's funny about this movie is that it
had some a lot of good ideas it did
it did execution was kind of mediocre oh
acting was mediocre
uh
what a strange [ __ ] movie this is
it's so weird like the more i think
about it like the [ __ ] weird it's
like so [ __ ] weird i don't really get
it i don't get it one thing that's good
about it is that it it adds a lot to
like vampire lore it's like what would
happen if you met vampires and they
liked you and then they wanted you to
work for them and they owned a whole
town
what would that be like
and then
what kind of deals would they try to
make with you
it's it's a movie kind of like that and
at the end there's a big payoff
uh where it's just like
vampire kill fast [ __ ] in 1989. or what
is this 87 87 87.
and so it does try to pay off in the end
it
does it pay off the kind
[Laughter]
it was the problem with the movie is
that it was uh
most of the characters were boring there
wasn't any compelling characters they
were either boring or they were [ __ ]
and unlikable yeah but not interesting
[ __ ] right the movie picks up when
um the jewish guy shows up
uh yeah that's the best character yeah
who's uh he's
you you go is he you think he's looking
for the vampires
he's actually looking for escape nazis
all right and he says are you a nazi
hunter he goes no i'm a nazi killer you
know he's just this old dude [ __ ]
running around [ __ ] killing he's
killed a bunch of nazis and he's got
their guns and
it's kind of wild and he he's the
kind of like the comedic relief in some
in some ways but he's also
he also keeps a story kind of moving
along he makes funny comments now they
get kind of tiresome the script is not
real
you know it's not great the dialogue but
really that's the only character in this
whole movie that stands out
yeah he's easily the best character yeah
the rest of the characters are are just
kind of bland
and the vampires are very bland
um even the vampire
lord the one that runs the place
he's just not very interesting he's not
an interesting character or an
interesting guy
the guy that they have playing him i
think is just too old and too kind of
conservative feeling you know
kind of feels like he should be selling
you some pepperidge farms or something
yeah pepperidge farm yeah yeah he's like
one of those
[Laughter]
so he doesn't make a very good vampire
and then when you see his true form
he doesn't look as good as sucking uh as
mr barlow that's uh that's quite an
understatement you just made there tom
uh he doesn't look
i mean the mat it's just a rubber mask
essentially yeah i think it's got some
pers like not prosthetics but like i
think the eyes move around and [ __ ] like
that but it's very rubbery looking yeah
yeah
it's just
i'm like
and then what's funny is that on the
cover they got mr barlow on the cover of
this movie yeah see that's a little bit
of a bait and switch there i was going
to take i was going to take an issue
with that because they are well honestly
the cover for a return for a return to
say it's a return to salem's lot yeah um
looks almost like the cover for the
original tv mini series salem's it's
tweaked though but they tweaked it a
little bit but it looks almost exactly
the same it's the same color scheme like
i said they got barlow on there a little
bit and stuff like that but the movie
doesn't really have anything to do with
the first movie there's like there's
literally like no continuity with it
there are no repeated characters nope um
it's it's it's a totally different movie
really they just said it in in salem's
lot and they didn't have to this was a
generic vampire movie basically well i
think that it started out like that okay
because what ended up happening was that
larry cohen
originally back when they made uh you
know the salem's lot adaptation for tv
that toby hooper ended up directing
larry cohen wrote a script for that and
i think he was supposed to direct it but
then they warner brothers whoever the
hell it was that made it they rejected
his script
so i think he just retooled it later on
and like warner brothers came and said
hey we're gonna do like a cheap jack
cash grab uh salem's lot you know sequel
do you want to do it and he was like
yeah sure i got like this story laying
around so he just kind of like tweaked
it into being more salem's lot-e i guess
i don't think it initially started out
as a salem's lot story now the thing
about it like you said there are some
good ideas in here and there are
actually some ideas in here that would
actually turn up
like in [ __ ] later on like true blood
like the true blood series
where it was just kind of like
it's but the thing is like i said
there's no continuity because in the
first movie right and in the book
um salem's lot is just like a regular
ass town right but then there's like the
marston house which is haunted or
whatever but then like barlow
uh and his little thrall guy like they
come there right and they just like move
into this house so but in this
in this iteration
the back story is that salem's lot has
been entirely populated by vampires
since like pilgrim days like they came
over it wouldn't work the mayflower
or not the mayflower but the boat before
the mayflower that crash or whatever it
was they have like some i was kind of
like dozing off because i was really
tired pseudo-history [ __ ] yeah they
had some pseudo-history and they're like
okay well we've been in this town for
like 300 years so i was like well that
doesn't even make any sense with the
first one because there weren't the
vampire came there well they said they
had drones who were
humans that they raised to run the store
fronts to make it look like a human town
but it still wouldn't work
that wouldn't have worked with the first
one
yeah too many humans in there that's
what i'm saying yeah that's what i'm
saying and it's just like they're all
you know and nobody's just like hey
town's full of vampires you know what i
mean it's not nobody knew that so it did
there was no continuity with it which
and like i said they don't bring up uh
mr barlow
they don't like i said the whole thing
is that and the weird thing about it is
that the vampires even though they're
ostensibly the bad guys
they're
their whole thing in the movie is that
they want to
maybe like integrate in with or they
want like humans to like understand them
like as a race they're drinking cowboys
so they're actually drinking cow blood
now they will drink human blood like on
special occasions like if it's someone's
birthday or something like that then
they'll be like all right just have a
busload of kids or you know what i mean
to drink all their blood it's fine but
normally they just like take a little
bit of blood from cows
and
initially i think the reason that they
want to talk to michael moriarty's
character who's an anthropologist is
they essentially want him to write their
bible i'm not really sure what the end
goal of that is it didn't make any sense
well because if they were vampires and
they were like afraid that humans
because if you found that there was like
a small town somewhere just you know for
example that was full of vampires you
would think that like humans would be
like yeah we need to go in there and
like wipe that [ __ ] out
so i don't really know
i don't see how the bible would have
helped him but that was yeah part of the
movie you know i mean it's just uh
it it did have some good ideas they just
weren't executed very well you can ki
you can kiss all that good acting and
all that gravitas of the first one
goodbye
that's not there this is more like an
action movie in a way like a suspense
action cheap jack action movie you know
this is like
on par with like
oh [ __ ]
oh when i was watching it it was
reminding me of other movies from that
time
uh all bad movies uh again
almost kind of like well it wasn't even
as good as basket case
no no i actually i actually i love
basketball it's just kind of
basket case kind of had a different it
kind of had a cheap look to it but it
was it was fun um it was also kind of it
was gross had a good story
it's just
don't see it
i
don't see it well i kind of feel like
like i said there's kind of like two
good ideas in here yeah there's a good
idea about a town like a secret a town
that's secretly full of vampires and
they're like well we just want everybody
to understand us and they have a human
and they're like right there bob that's
a cool idea i'm not saying that's not a
cool idea that's a cool idea you can
make a movie out of that but then like
halfway through
when you have the best character like
the nazi killer guy show up
um that's kind of a whole other movie in
itself yeah because it's like i kind of
like the idea of here's this guy who's a
nazi killer and he ends up in this town
looking for a runaway nazi and it ends
up that that dude is a vampire yeah like
that's also a good idea for a movie but
don't put them in the same movie it just
it was just seemed like
it was kind of all over the place and
the thing about the movie too is that i
mean the original salem's lot
the adaptation of it was like creepy you
know what i mean it was like really
creepy this is not scary at all i kind
of feel like well larry cohen his kind
of thing is he likes a lot of like dark
comedy and stuff and there are some of
it in this and some of it works like i
said the the nazi killer guy is like the
best character and he has some good
lines and like some good situations but
other than that and i did kind of laugh
at like the old lady saying that she
preferred human blood over cow blood and
she's like oh my husband says i have a
drinking problem like i thought that was
kind of funny yeah to me
but yeah it's just most of the jokes
were just kind of like really lame
but i don't know the tone of this was
very very strange it was very strange
and the weird thing about it so they
start out at the beginning michael
moriarty's character i can't remember
what their character names are so i'm
just calling them like what the actor
names are
michael moriarty's character
is
at the beginning he's do he's in like a
cannibal holocaust kind of situation
because i guess he's an anthropologist
and he's
filming
a human sacrifice with like some of the
whitest natives i've ever seen right
like whatever
i don't remember what what country was
he supposed to be that was in florida
well i know that yeah i know it was
florida
but it's like i don't know what country
it was supposed to be is what i'm saying
so he's like filming a set like a
sacrifice and he's just like oh neat you
know and like his buddy or whatever is
like man you were one cold-blooded son
of a [ __ ] or something like that
so while he's doing all this business
like he gets called back to the united
states by his ex-wife who's actually
played by nancy's mom from the original
nightmare on elm street she's only at
one scene so don't get too excited
but um
so basically she's like oh my god
something's wrong with our son you have
to come back to the us right away so he
comes back but it turns out that
nothing's actually wrong with the sun
like he didn't you know [ __ ] lose an
arm and a thresher or anything like that
but he's just an [ __ ] and the mom is
like sick of dealing with him
through the whole movie they've decided
they're gonna pawn him off on the dad
and jeremy i saw that i was reading a
review of this earlier that just called
him annoying jeremy like with both
capital letters the kid looks like baby
don johnson from miami vice yeah with
this little [ __ ]
with his pastel color and he had his
little [ __ ] it made me want to punch
him in the dick his little spirit
sperry doctor shoes and yeah socks and
[ __ ]
[ __ ] my mom was always trying to
dress me in that [ __ ]
he said that
damn i hate that [ __ ] [ __ ] when your
body is so ugly [ __ ] terrible it's so
ugly terrible
oh you should put those are so cute put
some slack look at the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
but yeah well and and this movie right
here is exactly why because this kid
looks like a total douche nozzle
throughout the whole thing and he's
really kind of like now the thing about
it is like he is really annoying and uh
and everything but
i will say because i'm always like
really amused by kids he's not really a
kid he's like how old is he supposed to
be 13 14 15 something like that so i'm
always like really amused by atrocious
character but by kids that like swear a
lot and this kid just like swears all
like a lot and i just i thought that was
funny
but i think like when you first meet him
like at the airport or whatever he's
like haven't you heard him [ __ ] up
you know what i mean he's like all right
i want him to be kind of like the kids
from the lost boys all right well lost
boys came out the same year as this yeah
they're trying to get it
i don't know they probably weren't
copying i'm just saying yeah that's what
they wanted something like out of lost
boys or something kind of like the kid
from t2
he was supposed to be a cool kid or the
kid from near dark yeah which also came
out the same year as this so right there
there's two much better vampire movies
yeah he's supposed to be a cool kid
but the way they directed him and his
acting and [ __ ] he just comes off
there's nothing redeeming about it he's
really really obnoxious he's just
obnoxious yeah i mean his dad is
obnoxious too yeah but his dad's far
less obnoxious and to be honest it's
like if that was my kid i would want to
like [ __ ] punt that kid across the
[ __ ] state his dad's just like a
like a [ __ ]
bumbling idiot just you know totally
[ __ ] ineffectual
helpless [ __ ] he just seems like he
doesn't know what he's what's going on
most of the time beta as [ __ ] you know
he doesn't know what's going on the
jewish dude eventually shows up he's in
his broken down jalopy and [ __ ] he's
basically you can tell i i instantly
recognize what's going on
he's playing colombo
he's investigating but you can tell that
he's doing a colombo impersonation he
didn't notice that it did seem like
doing colombo that guy is a film
director in his own right actually
samuel fuller yeah he shows up and the
movie kind of picks up because like i
said he's yeah i was like oh thank god
the movie saved right
this guy's here they got a real
character in here
he's beating all the kids and [ __ ] was
[ __ ] hilarious
yeah that was just twisting the keys
yeah child abuse [ __ ]
and he's like this is how you do it this
is how you do this is how you control
him yeah he likes
it it's like a controller it's like a
cat picking it like a mother cat picking
up a kitten like as you get the scruff
of the neck and the kid's like yeah and
it like immobilizes him and i'm like
nice yeah so
yeah so the jewish dude's totally
unacceptable too but he's like [ __ ]
the only redeeming quality because at
least he's got [ __ ] balls and he's
funny all right
[ __ ] shooting guns and [ __ ] and
shooting vampires in the head
which which works yeah yes
yeah it works
and uh
there's the only that he had one he had
one scene where he steps into the
vampires put a bear trap at the bottom
of the steps and it was a huge bear trap
with interlocking teeth on it
all right and that thing was a [ __ ]
bear traps are not that big i don't know
where these people get that idea you
could catch an elephant with that [ __ ]
that's what i was just that would take
the elephant's foot off yeah you know i
guess that just something that the prop
department made or something because i
was i was like man that would have
chomped that dude's leg right off yeah
[ __ ] you know i mean people don't
know how that [ __ ] works
he just shook it off like yeah and then
he's running around
that would have cut right through that
[ __ ] tibia
that happens a lot in movies i feel like
like somebody just gets like shot in the
shoulder or something like that there's
like i'm fine i'm just gonna shake
just a flesh wound they're like running
around and stuff i'm like you probably
shouldn't run because that makes your
blood pump faster you know you know i'm
just saying like uh yeah
there's only there was only one
believable
shot to a dude who just shook it off and
that was in the thing remember when the
norwegians
jumped out of the helicopter and the guy
had that hk 556 assault rifle and he
shoots he shoots that one dude with the
beard in the leg and he falls down and
back runs by and gives him a [ __ ]
bottle of whiskey and just keeps on
running
that's right
and he was [ __ ] crying and bitching
and moan and then later on they show him
in the infirmary and they're going oh
come on it barely grazed you it's a
it's a three-inch cut it just barely
broke the skin you know oh it's killing
me you know
that was the only one that was
believable you know five five six hits
you in the meat that especially back in
those days those little [ __ ] 55 grain
bullets that they used to exploded
[ __ ] reduce them put a [ __ ]
put a piece of hamburger in you the size
of a [ __ ] baseball that's what that's
what the damage looked like and if it
hits bone it just shatters bone that
[ __ ] was [ __ ] devastating
all that stuff is so when i laugh when
they show movies dudes just getting hit
oh it's just a flesh wound you know
shaking it off you know i just went
through the meat and then have full
mobility afterwards
yeah yeah that's like that's that's yeah
that's oh you know puts you in a world
of hurt but a world of hurt
trey says oh lord this movie was a real
riot i could not believe it when i saw
it yeah a for sure are they serious type
thing for me i'm just kind of like
it's one of those movies where if you're
into like so bad it's good movies then
it's like so what the [ __ ] that you
might find it entertaining
um because some people do like some
people have it's like a guilty pleasure
kind of movie the movie is joshing you
it's definitely just yeah it knows it's
[ __ ] up it was almost kind of like
it's just so weird like the tone of it
is so weird there's so much stuff going
on like i said there's good
ideas in there but it almost seems like
and this got a theatrical release like a
limited theatrical release yeah albeit
but
um yeah this like this went into
theaters and i was just kind of like i
don't know how much it cost to make it
didn't say on the wikipedia page maybe
like a buck 98 or so but um
it had a pretty big well i'm just i'm
i'm it's called hyperbole yeah making a
joke they spent money on it but i well
like i said i don't know how much one of
the weirdest things that happens early
on
because you know this is an 80s movie
so you know they have to have like the
bad
you know druggy punk rocker characters
yeah so
you get yeah i don't know why this like
stuck out to me but
so this town's full of vampires it's all
vampires or they're human they call them
drones like the humans that have to like
watch over them and blah blah but
apparently some people do kind of like
randomly drive through there sometimes
um and sometimes the vampires will snack
on them but sometimes not
so this car goes through the town
and there's was like three punk rockers
or something like that and like the cops
pull them over
and then they like start eating the one
and the one girl that's in there that
actually gets away but then she gets
eaten later on what the [ __ ] was her
deal like i know she was supposed to be
high and everything but has she ever
been high in her life because that's not
a high person yeah that what she was
doing was not a high person i'm i'm sure
it looked like a mental patient yeah i'm
not really sure what she was doing like
that weird thing she was doing when she
was talking about the talent of salem's
lot it's like it's a curse
or something like i'm just like what the
heck i was actually are you doing i was
trying to stop it immediately i was
actually trying to block that character
out
i mean she wasn't in it that long well
she was in it too long frankly but she
was only in it for a couple minutes and
then she got eaten by like some of the
other vampires but
that was the weird thing too is like the
vampires made like a big deal like when
they were trying to like schmooze
michael moriarty to like write their
bible or whatever and they're like yeah
we want to integrate into human society
and we want you to write it so people
can understand us because we've been
around all this time and like we're
older than humans and blah blah and we
don't even eat humans anymore except on
occasion but they eat so many people in
this movie yeah and i'm like who the
[ __ ] are you trying to kid look we're
just drinking from cows you know it's
like and we don't even kill the cows
that's better than what you guys do like
you guys chop them up and make
hamburgers out of them stuff like that
so
they got the school all rigged up to
teach the vampire children how evil
humans are
that's pretty cool i did like that i
liked that uh i mean i like the idea i
like that idea of like a little town
that's all vamp and they have their own
culture yeah like i said that's pretty
neat and like i said i think true blood
kind of did a similar thing like later
on like that tv series but so that's a
great idea but i kind of feel like it
was just it couldn't decide if
it wanted to be a horror movie or if it
wanted to be a comedy and it ended up
being like neither you know what i mean
like it's not scary and it's not all
that funny like there was a couple lines
in it that were funny that were supposed
to be funny but
a lot of it was just kind of
cringy i found it very cringy
and i couldn't even really
normally this kind of stuff i'd have
like a good time with it but i don't
know maybe i was just tired and crabby
and i was just kind of like
i was like i can't even it just seemed
like
interminable like it's you know what i
mean it's not even that long of a movie
but it seemed like five hours long
i don't know why
i don't know maybe it was just because i
was
sleepy and i didn't really feel like
watching it it just wasn't executed real
well
it really wasn't it just seems like it's
choppy and quality it's very thrown
together and it's weird because like
some of the special effects like some of
the vampire makeup like especially like
later on
so when they start like you know burning
everything up and everything like some
of the makeup looked pretty good
but then like when you had the main
vampire like who was the judge right i
don't even remember like the judge and
then he would vamp out he just looked
like he just looked like rubber face
yeah
and i don't really get
i mean you could watch this just don't
if you watch it as not a salem's lot
sequel thank you very much thank you
jeffy art fun silly fact as a jersey boy
i recognized the airport in the
beginning which is newark international
that's really funny i don't know if i
could uh i haven't been in
i mean i've been in airports but i don't
think that i've been in airports enough
times to like recognize a bit of movie
if i just saw like part of it but
so there's that
because they all kind of look very
similar
but i don't know it's just i'm not
telling people not to watch it but
there's a reason why people don't talk
about why people don't talk about it
that's why in a way that's kind of why i
was curious because i was kind of like i
had totally forgotten that there had
even been a sequel to salem's lot
and then i just saw it when i was
scrolling the other day and i'm like oh
i should probably watch that i think i
even put it in the patreon poll but it
didn't win and then i was just kind of
like let well let's watch it it's
probably like pretty fun or or something
and
i don't know it just it wasn't as fun as
i thought it was going to be
no they messed up some stuff they messed
up the way the vampires looked uh it
didn't it it wasn't scary
uh they the casting for the vampires was
bad
uh they just
they were just not nondescript vampires
just old people
basically yeah it's just
that's that's not what you want for a
vampire there really didn't seem to be
any any menace or danger
you know what i mean it was just kind of
like like they take annoying jeremy okay
for a time and they're trying to
indoctrinate him i guess or make him
into a vampire by using a very very
young tara reed obviously she this was
maybe her first movie she was a kid in
this she's like a little kid and um so
she's kind of like seducing
the boy
and trying to like and he's just like
hey i think that's a good idea i think
i'd like to be a vampire and he doesn't
want to leave the town and then michael
moriarty is kind of like going back and
forth about it it's like well maybe i'll
stay and write the bible or oh no maybe
i this isn't good and i should take my
son and get the [ __ ] out of here but he
just like equivocates like so much that
you're just kind of like what
but like i said you never really feel
like the the vampires are all that
threatening no even though they do eat
people even though they expressly say
that they don't but they do
but they're still not scary yeah
like you never feel like oh [ __ ] there's
we really got to get out of here because
we're like in danger
so i don't know the best thing about it
is the nazi killer guy yeah i mean he
doesn't make it the movie worthwhile he
doesn't make it worth watching but as
soon as he showed up and started
quipping and doing the stuff i was like
okay thank god like the movie saved like
something interesting is happening but
um yeah i don't know i'm just gonna get
into it but
it's kind of one of those movies that
it's pretty terrible
so
it's amusing in a terrible way
but i don't think i was in the right
frame it was i wasn't like in the mood i
remember remember what movie it was
reminded me of and it was mostly because
of the damn mass troll troll two
yeah it was it's like control it's it's
not that level
just happens to be in it it's as weird
as that yeah like the where you're just
thinking what you know what were they
thinking like with the concept yeah like
i said the concept of this one isn't
that weird it's just that there's two
concepts like with the nazi killer guy
and then that could have been two
separate decent movies but the fact that
they're both mashed into one movie
and there's no continuity and no
narrative it doesn't really make any
narrative sense
like either one of the things like they
don't overlap like those two stories or
anything like that but i don't know and
it's not much of a good
vampire survival movie either because it
doesn't seem like that there's any
threat from the damn vampires they just
run around killing them like it's easy
it's just
yeah that's another thing it's just kind
of like when they decide okay we should
get the [ __ ] out of here and we'll kill
the vampires then they just wait till
they're sleeping and just take them all
and then they're just like boop and then
they just burn the whole town down and
they're just like bye
yeah i was just kinda like okay well
uh caitlin higgins says i've only ever
read the salem's lot novel i didn't even
know there was a series of films too
well uh no it was a tv there was a tv
miniseries from 1979 which was directed
by toby hooper and i think it was came
it was like two or three parts like on
tv and 1979 and that's actually really
really good um i like that a lot there's
a lot of differences with the books
though from what i remember yeah there
are there are like mr barlow doesn't
talk in the movie but it's almost kind
of the way it's film is better that he
doesn't talk because he's [ __ ] keep
spooky looking i like that he doesn't
yeah i mean
i know he talks in the book but you can
get a way of [ __ ] the book like i
said you can get away with [ __ ] about if
you haven't seen tv series see it i got
it on on dvd it's good yeah and it's
like pretty easy shutter has it like
it's all over the place like
three hours maybe four hours it might be
longer than that i'm thinking
uh
i thought it i can't remember if it was
over two nights so maybe it's four hours
there's two of them there's one from the
70s and then there's another one i think
from the 90s the 2000s we're talking
about the one from the 70s the 70s the
old one i don't even remember did they
make another one of the 90s
i think they've been talking about
remaking it i think they made another
one in the 90s i think they're doing
another one that's coming out this year
i don't know if it's if it's a movie or
if it's a series somebody mentioned it
earlier i kind of feel like salem's lot
kind of needs a series
because a lot goes on you know what i
mean yeah um
yes uh samantha b said this sounds
terrible it is terrible yes man um
[Laughter]
it is terrible it's like i said it's i
don't know if it's worth watching some
people seem to like it just for how
terrible it is nobody thinks it's a good
movie yeah but
it's
it's all down to your
uh you know how
how willing are you to put up with
[ __ ] yeah like to just watch it and
don't think that it has anything to do
with like the original salem's lap book
or movie or anything like that other
than it taking place in that town
um yeah it is shoehorned into that and
yeah that's yeah and they and they bring
it up a bunch of times but other than
that there's like nothing that ties it
to the other stuff and it doesn't have
any like i said it doesn't have any
continuity with like the original story
so you know i'm gonna have to get down
there and start uh getting to work okay
danny rowling said i'd rather watch this
instead of maximum overdrive all day and
night ooh that's a hard one
i'd probably take maximum overdrive just
because that one is even more stupid um
and
ridiculous so i think it's more
entertaining this one's
ridiculous and terrible but i don't
think it's quite as over the top and
stupid but the language was the worst
one
the langoliers is pretty bad now i don't
remember
i remember a couple of things in it
being like kind of like really stupid
but i don't remember anything that
really stood out to me like oh my god
that was like epically stupid and i kind
of want to see it again like you know
what i mean because there's that kind of
thing the langoliers i remember just
being kind of boring
like like boring shading into terrible
right you know what i mean whereas
maximum overdrive is just like a really
big stupid
movie but it's fun kind of like for how
big and stupid and loud it is you know
what i mean yeah but this one is just
kind of meh i didn't love it i didn't
love it
uh zach says do y'all remember this pet
cemetery sequel
vaguely i vaguely remember that all
right so tom's got to go downstairs and
make some pizza yeah i got to make
something for us to eat so we could we
got movies you got to watch tonight yeah
we got to watch a long one tonight so uh
yeah so it's tuesday so tomorrow night
is our main show and i'm sure everybody
would be very excited i'm very excited
to do the show but we're going to do um
kind of like
scandals and legends of old hollywood so
we're gonna maybe talk about like may
west um maybe some of clark gable
charlie chaplin like stuff like that
like all kind of like scandals that um
went on back in the golden era of
hollywood i gotta poke through and see
which ones i want to talk about because
i know we did an old hollywood like
scandals of old hollywood thing before
like we talked about natalie wood and
stuff like that so we're not going to
repeat any of the same stuff but i'm
going to like talk about some other
things on there so hopefully you guys
can come by
and see us tomorrow evening at 6 p.m
eastern standard time and thanks
everybody for super chats and for
hanging out and we will see you guys
again tomorrow evening bye